[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este programa
especial de El Debate de Franz 24 hace
10 meses el 24 de febrero del 2022 las
tropas del ejército ruso cruzaron la
frontera e invadieron el territorio
ucraniano en una operación militar
especial según las palabras del kremlin
pero ante los ojos del mundo era y es
hasta el día de hoy una ocupación del
territorio de un país soberano el hecho
supuso entonces una escalada en un
conflicto que ya venía vigente desde el
2014 en el este de Ucrania y pasó a
denominarse abiertamente como una guerra
en pleno 2022 Europa comenzó a vivir
nuevamente en carne propia una guerra
abierta en su territorio después de 10
meses de Invasión y guerra en Ucrania
Entonces analicemos qué consecuencias ha
traído esto a nivel mundial el impacto
lo hemos vivido en todos los rincones
del planeta a nivel económico a nivel
energético y a nivel político entre
otros la invasión también ha dejado
hasta ahora 7 millones de personas
refugiadas y los que se han quedado en
el territorio ucraniano están haciendo
frente a la situación sin calefacción
sin energía y con escasez de alimentos a
esta altura entonces de la situación nos
preguntamos Qué es lo que está buscando
Rusia y cómo es ese orden mundial que
ellos están intentando establecer a
través de esta invasión al territorio
ucraniano Con qué apoyo están contando
ahora 10 meses después de haber iniciado
la operación especial militar como ellos
lo han llamado desde Moscú entendiendo
ahora que la guerra Pues también se ha
extendido más de lo que todas las partes
estaban esperando y que amenaza con
prolongarse aún más qué perspectiva hay
para este conflicto para el año 2023
pues para este especial del debate hemos
hecho Entonces poco en Ucrania el
balance de lo que deja el 2022 en este
conflicto que captó la atención de la
comunidad internacional y para conversar
sobre este tema tenemos a un panel de
primer nivel desde la ciudad de Córdoba
en Argentina se conecta Florencia
rubiolo ella es investigadora del
conicet y también secretaria de posgrado
de la universidad Blas Pascal también
está con nosotros desde Madrid en España
se conecta a Michelle testoni él es
profesor de la hay hay University y en
el estudio de France 24 nos acompaña
Víctor Mijares él es profesor de ciencia
política y estudios globales de la
Universidad de los Andes ubicada en la
ciudad de Bogotá ustedes nuestros
televidentes también ya lo saben hacen
parte de esta conversación de este
debate ustedes pueden dejar todos los
comentarios y las preguntas que ustedes
quieran hacer A través de las redes
sociales se las recuerdo estamos en
Twitter estamos en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentra como arroba el
debate_f24 arroba santilogo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta para que
dejen los comentarios numeral el debate
f-24 todo junto todo pegado no olviden
también que todos los contenidos de este
programa disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Florencia en la ciudad de Córdoba en
Argentina Florencia Bienvenida al
programa Gracias por estar con nosotros
en este especial del debate de France 24
y quiero comenzar
construyendo un panorama general de la
situación con las opiniones de ustedes
tres las consecuencias que deja entonces
a nivel mundial este conflicto y qué nos
dejó en evidencia este conflicto en
Ucrania que ya cumple 10 meses
bienvenida bueno Muchas gracias por la
invitación un gusto estar
para hacer un poco sintética no el creo
que el principal mi perspectiva desde la
economía internacional en este sentido
el principal
la principal consecuencia es por
supuesto la disrupción de comercio que
implica este conflicto dado que nos
encontramos frente a dos estados que son
grandes productores agropecuarios
particularmente de trigo concentra el
veinticuatro por ciento de la producción
mundial de este cereal Rusia y Ucrania y
la interrupción de la provisión
internacional también ha generado
determinado shocks en los precios
internacionales agrícolas y un proceso
inflacionario con escasos antecedentes
cercanos en realidad a nivel global y
por supuesto la producción energética de
Rusia que es
globalmente conocida y Y cómo la
reducción de las exportaciones implica
también
en los precios sobre todo
vamos a preguntarle a nuestro siguiente
invitado miquel en España para conocer
su panorama lo que deja este 2022 en
este conflicto bienvenido
Hola buenas tardes y gracias también por
la invitación pues este conflicto parece
desde mi perspectiva nos deja Nos está
dejando una herencia
por un cierto sentido bastante obvia
pero el otro sentido es totalmente
novedosa es decir la recuperación del
papel de la violencia del uso de la
fuerza de la invasión por un estado de
otro estado soberano cosa que en el
mundo y en industrializado en Europa no
veíamos desde la época de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial y lo que es de 2022 va a
yo creo a pasar por la historia en los
libros en el enciclopedia en la memoria
colectiva de todos nosotros es algo más
fundamental que por ejemplo fue el 11s
el 11 de septiembre de 2001 el mundo
como como decíamos el mundos de ayer no
para
hacerla una referencia una famosa novela
del siglo XX el mundo de ayer ya no está
Y todavía tenemos que descubrir lo que
va a ser el mundo de mañana tanto en
términos tecnológicos militares
políticos
diplomático Y por supuesto económico y
aquí en el estudio de France 24 Víctor
bienvenido como siempre Un gusto tenerlo
con nosotros su panorama general de esta
guerra Pues yo coincido con lo que dice
mis compañeros de panel en cuanto a el
impacto que ha tenido esto en materia de
economía política internacional en
materia por supuesto de ser
reconocimiento y de ese resurgir de la
violencia como un instrumento no voy a
decir que legítimo pero si un
instrumento que se usa efectivamente en
las relaciones internacionales eso hasta
cierto punto parecía que se podía dejar
de lado parecía que se podía quedar más
en el campo de la confrontación más
diplomática o económica pero esta guerra
nos llama la atención al respecto y dos
cosas que quisiera llamar la atención
con respecto a esto es Por una parte
esta guerra también nos deja cierto
reconocimiento un especial
reconocimiento por ejemplo a materias
primas como los hidrocarburos el
petróleo que parecía de algún modo ser
un hidrocarburo que un un una fuente
energética que pasaría un segundo plano
En donde había esfuerzos digamos
multilaterales por tratar de reducir las
emisiones Pues el petróleo se ha
convertido nuevamente al gas natural por
supuesto de los hidrocarburos se han
convertido en un factor importantísimo
en la geopolítica mundial ya lo eran
pero este es un campanazo importante que
nos llama la atención al respecto y el
segundo factor tiene que ver con la
evaluación de poder de los estados y
hablo hablo hablo particularmente de
algo es decir el balance de poder y
muchos en muchos programas como este
hablábamos acerca de cuál podría ser el
futuro la guerra cuánto podría durar
esta guerra y claramente lo hablábamos
de las perspectiva de los números de los
números totales brutos pero habría que
tomar en cuenta también el apresto
operacional la moral de las tropas
legitimidad de las de las causas y el
apoyo internacional que puede tener
porque ha demostrado que ha demostrado
con esta guerra que el balance de poder
visto de manera simple superficial no es
suficiente no es suficiente ese balance
de poder continuó con usted Víctor para
hacer la ronda la inversa y le pregunto
justamente por los actores que están
involucrados en este conflicto qué
evidenció este conflicto estos diez
meses de guerra en Ucrania en cuanto al
balance de poder no sé si usted está de
acuerdo vemos Que Rusia tal vez
militarmente no es tan fuerte como lo
era hace muchos años atrás el ejército
rojo el ejército soviético pero el
ejército ruso con esta invasión Ha
logrado poner en Jaque al mundo en
términos económicos políticos y
energéticos como ustedes lo han dicho en
este panorama inicial Qué más nos deja
esto a nivel político a nivel
internacional las relaciones estaban
tejidas como lo pensábamos se
construyeron nuevos nuevas alianzas
nuevos escenarios como lo ve pues yo voy
a comenzar con la primero no que tiene
que ver con con la situación de Rusia yo
a mí me gustaría advertir lo siguiente
sí creo que efectivamente habíamos
sobreestimado el poder de Rusia sobre
todo desde el punto de vista militar
pero tampoco quisiera que nos quedásemos
con la idea de que esta Rusia que
estamos viendo que ha tenido tantos
problemas para avanzar tantos problemas
para alcanzar sus objetivos que ha
tratado que ha tratado de cambiar de
objetivos para poder ajustar la realidad
a su a su propia narrativa tampoco es
una Rusia derrotada es decir Rusia está
usando una cuarta parte menos una cuarta
parte de su capacidad total convencional
en Ucrania no creemos que use la no
convencional Por supuesto que esto la ha
llevado una situación en donde en ese
balance
operacional y táctico pues está
enfrentando una situación fuera de su
territorio en donde va a ser muy difícil
que pueda avanzar mucho más pero no creo
que por eso por lo que hemos visto en
estos diez meses podamos concluir ya una
vez que Rusia está derrotada hay que ver
esto con mucho cuidado y con mucha
atención y desde el punto de vista de
balances de poder de de cambio en el
orden internacional Pues yo claramente
veo dos ganadores en esta guerra si es
que se puede hablar de ganadores hasta
el momento hasta el momento y esos
ganadores ganadores digamos desde el
punto de vista diplomático y geopolítico
están en los extremos en mi opinión son
China y los Estados Unidos china porque
logra que Rusia quede parcialmente
aislada en el occidente y que tenga que
mirar hacia China y que china pueda
digamos ser de algún modo también un
árbitro importante el futuro de Rusia
del futuro político económico y militar
de Rusia y en el caso de los Estados
Unidos Porque después de los años de
Trump y el debilitamiento del otan y de
la presencia de los Estados Unidos en
Europa que es fundamentalmente del punto
de vista militar por lo tanto pues la
otan sea reconfigurado y tiene
finalmente digamos lo que siempre anhela
lo tan que es un objetivo y un enemigo
Claro claro y así queda por lo menos
estas dos cargas de un lado China y de
un lado Estados Unidos le pregunto
entonces a miquele que hay de la Unión
Europea que ha sido un actor importante
pero que vuelve y dejan evidencia
ciertas falencias de la Unión Europea
Como por ejemplo esa
falta de agilidad para tomar decisiones
rápidas depender militarmente de Estados
Unidos y que en cierto punto a lo largo
de estos 10 meses no sé si usted
coincida conmigo en cierto momento Rusia
no lo veía como un actor con el que
tenía que sentarse a negociar e
intentaba hablar directamente con
Washington a través de Turquía o
directamente con Ucrania a través de
Turquía pero Europa la capacidad
diplomática se le agotó en cierto
momento como lo vio usted
es una una respuesta bastante compleja
porque hay luces y sombras en el papel
de la Unión Europea
primero porque la Unión Europea no fue
creada todo el proceso integración
europeo nunca ha sido creado para
resolver crisis exteriores sino para
y no producir crisis en su interno entre
sus países miembros segundo Porque tanto
política como legalmente en términos de
institucionales la Unión Europea tiene
una vinculación a doble hilo con la otan
la cual nunca ha perdido su papel
simplemente como todo tipo de
institución sobre todo institución
militar y defensa ha ido cambiando su
papel su piel no Yo siempre digo que la
otan es como serpiente que cambia piel o
serpiente bueno por supuesto y la otan
ha tenido varios momentos y entonces
diferentes políticas a lo largo de
décadas y ahora se está como decía el
colega justo un minuto antes ha tenido
que reconfigurar su papel reinventarse
en términos de defensa colectiva pura y
dura Pero esto no significa que todo lo
otro tipo de desafíos de retos que ya
estaban presentes en el sistema de
seguridad e Internacional de la gran
Europa
esto esto desafiaba y han desaparecido y
esto significa el calentamiento global
lo que significa el océano Ártico el
gran Norte significa la desertificación
los movimientos migratorios y la
inestabilidad política del sur de Europa
lo que yo creo hace ha hecho está
haciendo falta en el debate eurotlántico
es el papel del flacosur es decir del
Mediterráneo del norte de África donde
vemos una
dinamismo ruso que sigue siendo muy muy
efica En tercer papel Yo creo que la
Unión Europea
por supuesto tiene un rol muy ambiguo
porque como ha dicho el colega por un
lado tiene que
adecuarse un poco no a lo que está
pasando dentro este dos grandes
superpotencia tecnológica y militar que
son Estados Unidos y Rusia y por otro
parte tiene un papel muy evidente es
decir que la guerra en Ucrania se ha
sido desencadenada sobre todo por el
deseo de Ucrania de estar anclada al
occidente Y esto es un papel que hace la
Unión Europea no la otan claro es decir
las dos cosas pero en este caso un poco
behinds es la Unión Europea Entonces
tenemos que discutir más hablar más del
papel mucho más en claroscuros de la
Unión Europea
y que hay de Rusia Florencia cómo queda
Rusia después de estos 10 meses de
conflicto su imagen a nivel
internacional que tal vez
haciendo un recuento de lo que ha sido
el Gobierno del presidente Putin con ese
bache intermedio de la presidencia de
medelez una de las grandes apuestas fue
volver a catapultar a Rusia en el
escenario internacional y volverla a
poner como una potencia a nivel mundial
este trabajo se pierde un poco después
de esta invasión o qué balance hace
usted de la posición de de Rusia a lo
largo de estos 10 meses bueno
Sí definitivamente el balance a nivel y
magia internacional creo que
indiscutidamente negativo en términos no
solamente a imagen la imagen de lo que
conocemos como el occidente liberal no O
sea Europa occidental sea América del
Norte sea incluso América Latina donde
Rusia también ha perdido
el proceso de acercamiento que había
iniciado con varios países de la región
por porque fue condenado
la invasión fue condenada como la
violación al espacio soberano de un
estado
incluso mirando desde quizás miradas No
occidentales desde países emergentes
asiáticos como los Pina e India las dos
grandes potencias
que además hoy en día están están
funcionando de alguna forma como los
mercados alternativos que están
permitiendole a Rusia diversificar
exportaciones que no están O que están
bloqueadas hacia países occidentales
más allá de este de esta
de este apoyo de hecho
que los hechos en términos económicos
está produciendo desde China India
recibiendo las exportaciones Rusia rusas
en términos políticos diplomáticos ni
china ni India
han demostrado un apoyo
total digamos concreto a la política
rusa ambos gobiernos tanto el emoji como
el de chichipin En algunos momentos han
manifestado la disconformidad o la
incomodidad con el conflicto entre Rusia
y Ucrania la necesidad de llegar a una
salida a una resolución pacífica de esta
sí de la controversia Lo que implica que
Rusia ha perdido
posicionamiento de imagen a nivel
internacional no solo en occidente que
es un dato evidente sino también en sus
en estos socios emergentes asiáticos
creo que en resumen Rusia ha perdido
espacios a nivel internacional el
resumen de Florencia sobre la posición
rusa paso a preguntarles ahora por unas
de las grandes consecuencias que deja
este conflicto y son los 7 millones de
ciudadanos ucranianos que han tenido que
abandonar su país para irse a países
vecinos o países de la Unión Europea o
incluso un poco más allá muchos también
han llegado a países del continente
americano
desencadenó una crisis humanitaria de
Gran calibre en el este de Europa y
sobre todo mucha presión para algunos
países como Rumanía o moldavia que no
estaban preparados para hacer frente a
esta situación el invierno no ha
comenzado oficialmente en Europa y la
crisis energética pues ya la están
viviendo muchos países y falta ver qué
sucede allí paso a preguntarle a miquele
sobre esta situación humanitaria lo que
significa para la Unión Europea hacer
frente a esta llegada de ucranianos a su
territorio a estos países vecinos un
país como moldavia que ya tiene
muchísimos problemas a nivel económico y
también ese doble rasero que ha sido
blanco de críticas para Europa Si recibe
a los ucranianos pero a los sirios y a
los iraníes y a los iraquíes le cerraban
las puertas en la frontera polaca
pues desde luego estamos viendo un doble
rasero de
afortunado afortunadamente de Gran
solidaridad hacia el ucraniano Pero por
otro lado y tenemos gobiernos de toda
Europa del este muy simpatéticos muy
cercanos a los millones de refugiados
desde Ucrania y trazados como hermanos
Pero por otro lado sabemos lo que pasó
los años pasado con los afganos los
sirios los irakeno y todo lo que venían
del oriente medio por otro lado yo creo
que lo que ha sido mencionado es decir
la capacidad de resiliencia política
económica
energética desde luego de muchos países
que se están viendo
está avalancha ya sobre sus hombros
sobre su cabeza Cómo llegamos a la
primavera este es una gran pregunta y
creo que
yo no soy un experto de economía Así que
espero que mi compañeros puedan
contestar de manera más eficaz a este
tipo de preguntas pero lo que yo creo
Inevitable Me parece que ahora ya es esa
realidad tanto en Europa como Estados
Unidos tenemos que convivir con
economías con mucha deuda y con mucha
deuda vamos acabando con la deuda hay un
acuerdo político para que como después
de la Grande Guerra y la Segunda Guerra
Mundial se acaba la deuda se perdone las
deuda sino nuestras economías tienen que
vivir con mucha deuda y tenemos que
fabricar más deuda
el tema económico es el gran impacto que
tal vez deja esta guerra también además
de lo humanitario Víctor aquí en el
estudio de France 24 la Unión Europea
Hasta cuánto puede soportar esta crisis
humanitaria o por lo menos estos países
moldavia que no es integrante de la ue y
Rumanía que le han dado digamos una
cachetada no dejarlo entrar al Tratado
de schengen y ahí molesta entre bucarest
y Bruselas hay fisuras también en la
Unión Europea en cuanto al manejo de
esta crisis y esa fisuras vienen desde
antes de la guerra recordemos la crisis
de migración de migración de migrantes
en la Unión Europea en 2015 donde quedó
en evidencia que había muchos problemas
para coordinar políticas de recepción de
migrantes y de refugiados ahí la señora
Merkel tuvo que enfrentar digamos de
como una rebelión por parte de su de su
de sus vecinos Entonces el el asunto
migratorio se ha convertido en un asunto
digamos muy delicado no solamente en
Europa lo estamos viviendo también en el
continente americano en la frontera Sur
en la frontera entre los Estados Unidos
y México que se ha convertido en una
frontera tan caliente siempre lo por
supuesto pero con la migración se ha
convertido algo mucho más difícil y lo
que están experimentando países
Centroamericanos pero muy Especialmente
con respecto a esta guerra yo creo que
ha quedado en evidencia que los
problemas migratorios van a ser
problemas fundamentales para lo que
queda al menos la primera esta primera
mitad del siglo 21 la movilidad humana
no solamente motivada por deseos de
mejorar la calidad de vida sino huyendo
de conflictos huyendo de regímenes
autoritarios huyendo situaciones
económicas extremas huyendo de cambio
climático digamos de climas extremos va
a ser quizás uno de los problemas más
importantes no sé si el más Pero quizás
de los problemas más importantes que
vamos a tener en la agenda y esta crisis
ucraniana y esta oleada de migrantes
Pues nos está adelantando un poco lo que
vamos a ver en un futuro cercano ya no
solamente de Europa sino en otras
Fronteras del mundo claro y también hay
que decir esa frontera de Estados Unidos
hasta allí También llegaron varios
ucranianos a través del territorio
mexicano tratando de entrar a Estados
Unidos para escapar de la guerra en
estatura vale la pena volver a ser
balance o análisis de lo que está de lo
que piensa Rusia qué es lo que busca
Rusia después de 10 meses con este
conflicto con esta invasión en algún
momento el presidente Putin dijo que
estaba buscando un rompimiento de ese
orden internacional en donde Estados
Unidos no fuera el país líder pero este
conflicto esta invasión sí va a provocar
ese rompimiento de ese orden mundial que
piensa Florencia
Bueno definitivamente pienso que no no
va a provocar un rompimiento del orden
internacional de este orden
internacional
no en lo inmediato y no como
consecuencia solamente este conflicto y
tampoco por el potencial ruso ni el
económico ni el militar ni el político
hoy en día el orden internacional que
aparte es un concepto tan vago No tan
amplio tan difícil de definir para que
uno puede entender que el actual orden
internacional emergido después de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial sigue teniendo
como principal líder
a los Estados Unidos no es el único país
ni la única potencia que se beneficia
del actual orden internacional entonces
quienes sostienen y contribuyen a
mantener las principales Pilares de este
orden que entre ellos se destacan
La Libertad El libre comercio no en la
libre circulación de bienes servicios
capitales
donde esto ha servido y alimentado el
crecimiento y la emergencia de China
como segunda economía mundial
digamos china emerge Dentro de este
orden internacional y aún hoy no solo se
beneficia de él sino que aparte
contribuye a sostenerlo con su
participación en numerosos organismos
multilaterales que no solo en los cuales
no solo participa sino que aparte ha
comenzado a construir
organismos multilaterales Bajo su propio
liderazgo pero emulando las formas de
los organismos multilaterales
emergidos del orden liberal Sí entonces
bajo estas premisas y viendo esto donde
no solo Estados Unidos se beneficia sino
se benefician diferentes potencias
países europeos diferentes países en
vías de desarrollo no todos Y en
diferentes grados se ha beneficiado
India sea beneficiado china
uno puede
difícilmente pensar que la sola voluntad
de Putin en este caso pueda alterar
sacudir y reconstruir el orden
internacional solamente a partir de este
conflicto es posible que de hecho va a
llevar muchas más
voluntades
la modificación del orden internacional
que solamente la de Rusia
miquele y de este conflicto
mucho se ha hablado de las alertas que
hubo de los mensajes claros que envió el
kremlin previo a la invasión sí había
alertas claras de esta invasión y el
mundo no las entendió y por eso estamos
en este escenario hubo forma de
prevenirlo o simplemente Esto sí fue una
sorpresa para la comunidad internacional
esta invasión
bueno Esto fue
era un conflicto enquistado como se ha
dicho desde el principio de este
programa empezó cuando del 2014 o en
Ucrania por supuesto empezó en el 2008
con la invasión parcial de Georgia de la
parte entrenal del país Georgia o no
empezó o fue
fue evitado una un principio de
conflicto cuando ya en el 2008 la otan
sobre todo por mano de Francia y
Alemania
se opuso a la al ingreso de Ucrania y
Georgia a la
otan sí Este es un conflicto que tiene
mucho recorrido
se puede alcanzar un difícil de alcanzar
ahora mismo un alto fuego porque los dos
actores los dos los principales actores
en el conflicto es decir Rusia y Ucrania
han definido de forma diferente lo que
para ello es ganar
lo que es un conflicto territorial
significa que el espacio no se puede
multiplicar a diferencia del dinero o de
otro bienes el territorio lo espacio lo
kilómetros cuadrados las ciudades no se
pueden replicar Así que yo creo que es
un conflicto que parece mucho No ya la
segunda sino la Primera Guerra Mundial
es un conflicto que como casi todo la
guerra que conocemos la historia sabemos
cómo y cuándo empiezan
desconocemos Cómo y cuando terminan Qué
consecuencia tienes y me parece que
vamos por esta Senda es decir
y Rusia y Ucrania en un cierto momento
tendrán que acordarse Me parece que
todavía el espacio de maniobra es muy
muy pequeño no espacio sí Y Cuando un
día llegaremos a un acuerdo a ver qué
acuerdo el riesgo es de tener un
conflicto que sigue enquistado en toda
la frontera occidental de Rusia y la
frontera oriental de Ucrania o lo que
será Ucrania y en este caso hay que que
hablar también del papel muy ambiguo de
Bielorrusia Y qué hará Bielorrusia y
sobre todo lo que harán la potencia
media intermedias que son lateral de
exportadoras de energía que son otro
gran ganador de este conflicto Claro que
sí aquí en el estudio Víctor estamos
hablando de tratar de entender ese papel
que tiene Rusia en este conflicto y lo
que está tratando de provocar a nivel
internacional y Florencia hablaba de
como china ha surgido como una potencia
y bueno es Clara esa relación que hay
entre Moscú y Beijing qué tan fino es
Halo de unión entre los dos países
porque ambos van por el mismo interés
ser los que controlen el orden
internacional esta relación que en este
momento es bastante amistosa que tanto
puede aguantar cuando el interés es el
mismo Pues creo que la relación digamos
que sea se ha planteado como una
relación amistosa y que efectivamente
los dos líderes Sí y Putin también han
jugado un poco eso pues desde luego que
hay intereses encontrados pero no creo
que necesariamente tenga que ver con una
idea de disputa por la primacía mundial
el caso de Rusia no lo veo como una una
potencia que esté ni en esa liga ni
orientada en esa En esa dirección
pareciera ser más como lo dijo en su
momento el expresidente estadounidense
para cubama que Rusia se está
comportando y es efectivamente más una
potencia regional que una potencia
mundial Entonces en ese sentido Habría
que ver cuáles son las prioridades de
Rusia si Rusia efectivamente se va a
mantener y va a tratar de reconstruir un
espacio económico o un espacio de
influencia política
creo que va a ser muy difícil ahora
sobre todo porque en el caso solamente
los Estados Unidos han transferido a
este momento más de 54 mil millones de
dólares a a Ucrania en materia de ayuda
militar estamos hablando de un país que
tiene apenas doce mil millones de
dólares de presupuesto militar le
inyectamos 54 mil para no hablar del
resto de las ayudas entonces ahí Rusia
va a tener muchos problemas con lo cual
yo creo que si bien hay algunos
objetivos en los cuales podríamos pensar
que hay una distancia entre Beijing y
Moscú creo que las de ganar Las tienen
este caso china que va a tratar de
imponer sus condiciones sobre todo en el
mercado energético sobre todo en en el
futuro y cuál va a poder ser digamos la
línea de acción política por parte de
Rusia no estoy diciendo que se había
convertido en un estado digamos vasallo
de China pero China tiene en este
momento una una posición de poder Mucho
mejor mucho más favorable que la de la
de Rusia y por otro lado tenemos el
hecho de que el sistema político ruso
Aunque con el sistema político chino
También estamos haciendo
transformaciones importantes Pero
todavía es un sistema mucho más complejo
el sistema político ruso es demasiado
putincéntrico con lo cual Eso hace que
todo el estado y todo el andamiaje de
funcionamiento sea muy frágil porque
depende de un solo hombre de la salud de
ese hombre del Estado mental de ese
hombre y de las coaliciones internas que
él pueda mantener Entonces veo la tarea
de Rusia de ser un poder mundial lo veo
muy cuesta arriba va a luchar por tratar
de ser un poder regional y para eso
necesita el apoyo chino y no hay claro
un claro
heredero de ese poder que deje Putin no
hay una figura política destacada a
nivel nacional dentro de la federación
que pueda uno señalar y decir él puede
ser el sucesor de Putin en unos cuantos
años eso también dificultará que se
prolongue o que se pueda mantener en el
tiempo esta forma de gobierno y este
estatus que ha provocado Putin allí en
Rusia vamos ya para el toque final del
programa vamos a hablar entonces de lo
que puede venir para el 2023 voy a dejar
varios minutos para que ustedes puedan
tocar diferentes temas comienzo entonces
con Florencia de lo que puede ser
entonces para el 2023 este conflicto se
va a agudizar la crisis energética
económica a nivel mundial se va a
prolongar este conflicto puede haber Tal
vez un escenario de negociación con los
actores que han tratado de ayudar para
para una mesa de negociación está
hablando por ejemplo de Turquía que ha
jugado ahí un papel bastante ambiguo en
este conflicto muy difícil de entender
lo que quieren allí y
qué se puede esperar entonces de esta
guerra Florencia
Bueno
realmente la extensión que pueda tener
la guerra es muy difícil de prever se
preveía que iba a ser una guerra mucho
más breve pasaron diez meses seguimos en
el conflicto con la casi igual o mayor
intensidad que cuando inició por lo
tanto no hay ninguna
posibilidad de pronosticar que finalice
en un periodo pronto o cercano del
proceso de negociación ha sido múltiples
veces los intentos de proceso de
negociación han sido múltiples veces
frustrados hay diferentes actores que
intentaron jugar ese rol hace muy poco
India manifestó de alguna forma en el en
la Cumbre del g20 en Bali una posición
que se acerca a una idea de mediación
negociación manteniendo una relación a
un cercana con Rusia y también con
occidente de alguna forma mostrando esa
posibilidad de convertirse en un puente
puede ser que India fue ese rol
lo veremos en el 2023 va a tener un rol
central como líder de las economías
emergentes Así que creo que ahí puede
haber
un puede haber Alguna algún indicio no
de de de un proceso de resolución creo
que una de las consecuencias importantes
Más allá de la económica a nivel global
que ya mencionamos antes que todos
tocamos creo que el impacto en Ucrania
va a ser un impacto muy
eso y muy profundo pero lo va a hacer
por mucho tiempo
en una contracción del 36 Sí es que me
quedan pocos minutos debo darle la
palabra para que pueda hacer su
conclusión mikele 40 segundos para su
conclusión que viene para el 2023 en
este conflicto
intentaré intentar ser muy muy rápido
pues
el año que viene es una curiosa
coincidencia porque son van a ser 50
años después
que es riquísinger dijo que en 1973 iba
a ser el año de Europa o sea donde
Europa en el proceso de distensión en
ese de la Guerra Fría entre Estados
Unidos y a la unión soviética hubiera
podido jugar un papel importante Sí yo
creo que y más bien una esperanza que
2023 puede ser el año de China que
quiere ser China de grande de adulta
Porque si hay un actor que puede parar a
Rusia es decir el conflicto es chino
pero la diplomacia china no solo Turquía
china ha sido muy ambigua ha respaldado
hasta ahora Rusia de manera respaldado
pero
no hasta el final nos vemos ningún
estado el mundo ha enviado tropas a
Rusia
si hay alguien que puede parar esta cosa
China y aquí en el estudio para el
cierre Víctor un minuto Bueno me voy a
atrever algo no he pensado en escenarios
entre más probablemente menos probable
más impacto menos impacto y me parece
que lo más probable Pero quizás no tenga
tanto impacto va a ser la reutilización
de la guerra es decir que esta guerra se
mantenga se queda quede como un
conflicto un poco latente en donde se
reduzca el número de tropas en donde se
pueda digamos ganar y perder terreno
allí obviamente cualquier ganancia es
importante para Ucrania y la
restauración de su soberanía pero esa
reutilización desde luego puede
llevarnos escenarios de mayor impacto en
que ligeramente menos probable Como por
ejemplo el de un cese progresivo de
hostilidades esto puede venir dado por
una mediación o puede venir dado
simplemente por el agotamiento el
agotamiento sobre todo económico el
agotamiento digamos de las tropas
comportamiento político dentro dentro de
Rusia y allí yo veo digamos dos dos
posibilidades una posibilidad que las
dos creo que son malos escenarios para
Rusia una situación digamos de de no
decir de quiebra pero prácticamente
quiebra económica de Rusia en una
situación en donde vamos a vivir una una
importante recesión económica en todo el
mundo y Rusia no está en las mejores
condiciones para enfrentar una situación
como ésta o Y esto no es io podríamos
también tener digamos alguna especie de
Victoria pírrica por parte de Rusia esto
lo veo mucho menos probable pero es que
cualquier forma de Victoria que pueda
tener Rusia Como por ejemplo quedándose
con una parte del territorio ucraniano
va a ser un costo muy alto Muy alto y
ese costo no solamente lo veo en
términos de
de lo que ha sido la destrucción de la
propia economía rusa la contracción de
esa economía rusa sino también el
crecimiento militar de países como
Ucrania pero también de Polonia y sobre
todo el grupo visado y estamos viendo la
proyección
me dice los Estados Unidos hacia el este
con lo cual Rusia va a quedar en una
situación mucho peor de la que estaba
Cuando comenzó esta guerra mucho más
arrinconada en términos militares pues
les agradezco a los tres invitados por
haber estado con nosotros hoy finalizó
rápidamente diciéndoles
agradeciéndoles por la sintonía por el
programa de hoy que estuvo bajo la
producción de Laura garzón y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera siga con nosotros
[Música]